it's time for et social study your quick  look at what the stars are posting  online Chrissy Teigen and John Legend  are having the time of their lives in  Morocco with their baby girl Luna oh the  model shared these sweet snaps on  Wednesday enjoying the last day of  vacation flip or flop star christina el  Moussa looked absolutely fabulous  rocking matching swimsuits with her  daughter Taylor for an L space swimwear  photoshoot get excited Love Actually  fans the cast of the 2003 rom-com is  reuniting on Red Nose Day including a  Hugh Grant Liam Neeson and Keira  Knightley  Marc Anthony has moved on from his ex  Shannan de Lima the 48 year old singer  hit the red carpet at the my a stroke  hairs gala with his new girlfriend 21  year old Mariana downing he also shared  photos from the event on Instagram  posing with actor Jimmy Smits and going  over his script  you